welcome back to my round three recap
from the Qatar Masters I do appreciate
everyone chiming in to answer my
question and the last recap how to
pronounce the name of this country it
seems like the typical English way of
saying Qatar is Qatar so I think I'll
stick with that but anyway uh this is my
round three game I played a fellow
American actually fellow Missourian
Josiah steeran we traveled all the way
to guitar from Missouri to play each
other uh this is a friend of mine he is
a student at mizou and we actually
played for the first time OTB a few
months ago at a local St Louis chess
club quads tournament it was a Friday
night quads and we had a really
interesting game which I actually filmed
but I never actually uploaded the game
to YouTube
so I think what I'll do is if this video
gets 2,000 likes I'll upload that game
to YouTube and you'll see another really
cool crazy battle in that game I had
played the London opening but in this
game I decided to not play the London
opening and I played E4 on move one now
I talked to Josiah after the game and he
told me that he was mainly preparing
the London but then he realized that I'm
capable of playing a lot of different
things so yeah E4 is definitely one of
the things I I sometimes like to play
and I was expecting him to play the
Sicilian which he did and why is there
so many side variations let me um
delete I copied this from the broadcast
so uh maybe there is engine analysis run
but no spoilers just yet let me uh hide
everything and yeah so coming into this
game I was expecting Sicilian and I
opted for Knight to C3 and I was trying
to Target some lines where if he plays
Knight C6 I would play Bishop B5 and
there's a lot of like tricky variations
that I was ready to go into uh for
example Knight D4 Knight F3 it's a a fun
opening to prepare from the white side
but he did not play Knight C6 rather he
played Pawn to D6 and before the game
like I was checking his stats of like
the moves he plays in this position and
the only moves I could find that he
plays is Knight
C6 sometimes E6 and sometimes G6 but I
don't think there is a single over
theboard or online game where he's ever
played D6 so this is definitely a
surprise and before the game I I kind of
made a mental note that if he plays his
move I would just play a Grand Prix
attack and the Grand Prix is F4 in this
position and essentially to get a setup
with Knight F3 Bishop C4 castle and then
get some quick attack in the early
middle game so um yeah I was still kind
of within opening preparation after G6
kn3 Bishop G7 Bishop C4 and then he
plays Pawn to
E6 and I pretty quickly castled now it
turns out that I had another option in
this position and he actually told me
after the game that he checked with the
engine and the engine apparently really
likes this move d4 which I knew it was
an idea in some positions but I didn't
realize how strong it can be immediately
I think the idea is after takes white
has Knight B5 and there's maybe some
cases where white can play C3 and then
try and Target the D6 Pawn cuz um yeah
it's it's a bit awkward that black has
committed to E6 and G6 uh D6 is
definitely a weakness with the bishop
not defending it from f8 or
E7 so unfortunately we did not go into
that uh I think that was my first chance
to get some Advantage but I castled he
plays Knight E7 and now I play D4 and
this is a little bit different because
after it takes Knight B5 he plays a move
Pawn to D5 and it's a bit uh concrete
would say where black is forcing matters
forcing some Liquidation in the center
uh I pretty much had to take on D5 and
then he takes back with pawn and even
though it looks a bit ugly for black
having these Double D pawns um black is
opening the position and I still have to
work to win my Pawn back so I Retreat to
B3 he plays Knight C6 and I take on
D4 and yeah once we got to this position
I was feeling feeling pretty comfortable
cuz I won back my pawn and I'm
essentially playing against this
isolated uh D Pawn which can be a
long-term weakness for black and on top
of that my pieces are pretty harmonious
like C3 is coming I have good control
over the blockading square on D4 Bishop
E3 is on tap so I felt like even though
I wasn't super well prepared for the
opening uh I got a position that I can
definitely handle so going forward from
here he castled I played Pawn C3 he
plays Rook E8 and I played Bishop to E3
so just completing development and even
though I'm putting the bishop on a
square where it's not defended and The
Rook from E8 can potentially attack it
uh there's not really any tactics
immediately for black but he plays on F5
which is a um confrontational move
hitting the bishop pressuring D4 I drop
back to F2 and then he plays Knight to
E3 so this is basically forcing me to
trade if I don't want to lose material
had to take on E3 after Rook takes E3 uh
I took a bit of time here to play the
move Queen to
D2 uh initially I had the the thought
that maybe I can win a pawn with Knight
to C2 attacking the rook and unleashing
the queen so essentially winning
D5 the reason why I didn't go for this
is because let's say he just Retreats
the rook and I take on
D5 then black gets a lot of active play
with Queen B6 check and if King H1
Bishop E6 I think there's a lot of cases
where black wins back the pawn with a
very fine position so didn't want to go
for that uh Queen D2 was just a lot more
natural attacking the rook and preparing
to get my other Rook into play and here
he plays Rook E4 I play Rook ae1
challenging his Rook uh one other option
which he told me after the game maybe I
I should have considered a bit more
seriously it was Bishop C2 I think the
reason why I played Rook E1 first was I
didn't think there's much of of a
difference between hitting the Rook
right away or just challenging The Rook
on E file but as we're going to see
there is a difference because in this
position he jumped on the opportunity to
take on D4
not once but twice and after the trade
he played a very interesting move Queen
to
B6 and this is essentially the beginning
of a lot of chaos because when he plays
Queen B6 this move is essentially based
on a very deep
calculation and we can see from the time
oh he actually didn't spend too long he
spent about 6 minutes uh but actually
before he played this move he had his
head down on the table it looked like he
was sleeping he was just like doing this
and I could tell that he was calculating
deeply and um yeah once he put his head
down I I kind of knew that Queen B6 was
coming because the resulting variation
is super super deep and interesting and
very hard to fully understand what's
happening so to explain what's happening
here uh of course black is attacking the
pawn and I didn't really want to take on
e4 CU after takes black no longer has l
a d Pawn this Pawn could be a a strength
for black it is a pass Pawn can be
supported by the bishop and my D Pawn is
a bit weak on D4 pinned and attacked by
the
queen so the main consideration here was
this move Bishop takes
D5 and it's a move by end of the playe
now another another thing he told me
after the game was Bishop C2 was an
option but I spent most of my time
calculating this and going forward from
here it just gets wild because he takes
on D4 at first it looks like okay black
is going to win material like he's
hitting my queen and Bishop and setting
up some discoveries against my king but
I have a counter punch Rook E8 check
forcing King G7 my queen and Bishop are
still attacked but I have to move Queen
C3
and this is what happened in the game
with Queen C3 I'm pinning The Rook so he
has no immediate chance to like win my
bishop or discover check and uh black
essentially has to get out of the pin
and the way he did that was by playing
King
H6 and I had seen this from a distance
and I really thought that there's no way
that this can be like good for black
with a king just coming out and like
Queen active but it turns out to be very
tricky for white to deal with because
he's threatening the bishop but also
just threatening Rook D3 with discovered
check to win my queen so my only way to
get out of that is King to
H1 and even though I'm leaving my Bishop
attacked and undefended I am hitting the
bishop on C8 so when he takes on
D5 yeah when when I saw this position
coming I thought I was going to just
take on C8 pretty quickly but but once
we got to this
position I realized I I don't have to
take the bishop like The Bishop's pinned
it's not going anywhere it's pinned to
the A8 rook and I started looking for
other
options and after somewhat of a long
think I concluded that the most
interesting path forward is to play this
move Pawn
F5 and when I played this move I wasn't
entirely sure what's happening but it
just looks super interesting because I'm
cutting off the scope of the Bishops I'm
setting up some ideas of Queen H3 and
maybe later F6 to harass a king um also
opening up this diagonal so uh maybe in
some cases Queen E3 check could be a
resource and it's not great for black
it's probably actually very bad for
black to take the pawn because then I
take take and then I have something like
Rook G8 and yeah Queen G7 and queen H3
are both threats so this should be
losing for black
so going back after I played F5 I
thought that I should have like decent
chances to maybe win the game um but he
was still pretty resourceful uh he
played the move Queen D4 ensuring that
yeah my queen no longer can really fight
for this diagonal and he just wants to
trade queens and be up a bishop so I
don't allow that I play Queen to
H3 and after King f8 I played Queen to a
A3 and when I came up with this sequence
I was super
excited about the prospect of just
destroying him with Queen
f8 but the problem was I just didn't
evaluate things properly and I just
completely underestimated his next move
in this position now before I go forward
I want to go back and show what I should
have played um I I regretted it pretty
soon after going for uh for what I went
for but I should have just take on C8
this was my chance to simplify a bit and
I think it's very likely that the game
would have ended in a draw like if he
takes and then I take uh there's a lot
of situations where the king is just a
bit too weak like even if he wins a pawn
there's a line queen f8 queen G7 Queen
E7 um I'll admit I didn't calculate this
fully during the game CU I was more
interested in in this queen H3 move but
uh yeah I probably should have gone for
this so let's go back and I'll show what
happened in the game cuz when I play
Queen H3 I thought I was being like so
clever I forced the king back I'm
threatening Queen f8 but it turns out
that he just simply blocks the diagonal
he plays Rook
C5 and I was getting decently low on
time I took a lot of time here just
trying to figure out like where is my
counterplay like I'm down a bishop what
to do next originally I was casing Queen
C5 and I thought this was the more
critical line and I was looking at B4
I'm still not sure what's happening here
but I think Rook C5 was just a simpler
option and uh at this point I'm I'm
scrambling for any chances to keep my uh
my counter playay alive I chose to play
Queen B3 after burning most of my time
falling below 3 minutes and the point of
Queen B3 is I am trying to Target the F7
Pawn so the threat is to take on G6 and
then have a bunch of attackers on F7 and
I was also setting up a trick with this
move that at first it looks like Bishop
E6 should just win for black because the
queen and Rook are both hanging but I
had a sneaky trick here Rook takes E6
after Pawn digs E6 Queen digs B7 and
yeah white should be doing fine winning
The Rook on
A8 so yeah sadly that didn't happen uh
he did not fall for any sneaky tricks he
played the move Queen F6 which is a very
nice stabilizing move for black ensuring
I don't really have play on the file and
now my Pawn is pinned to my Rook on F1
um I do want to go back actually cuz I
don't think I addressed an important
point that the reason why I can't play
F6 here and I really wanted to make this
move work but I can't play this because
there's Queen takes
F6 and like even though the queen and
Rook are both hanging like I I'm not
winning anything here if I take the
queen I just get mated and if I take the
Rook then yeah black just takes on F1
and I'm losing so yeah there's so many
lines where F6 just doesn't work so
going back to what happen in the game
after Queen B3 Queen F6 my counter
chances are just fizzling I played the
move Queen D1 trying to defend my rook
and set up maybe some idea of taking on
G6 but he was very precise with just
shutting down all my play he played G5
now the file is closed what to do next I
tried to throw the kitchen sink with the
move H4 but um
yeah wasn't much of a kitchen sink and
he simply caught whatever I threw at him
uh played a nice move Rook to C4
preparing Rook H4 and now black is a one
actually seizing initiative I played the
move Pawn takes Pawn he takes and I
played Pawn F6 but his King finds safety
on
H6 and yeah I I was just trying not to
flag I played Queen D3 with two seconds
left uh backing The Rook maybe trying to
set up rook h8 ideas to eventually
checkmates but yeah White's play is just
too slow after Rook H4 King
G1 uh he really puts a nail in the
coffin with his next move Bishop H3
threatening mate threatening my Rook um
I didn't resign I still tried to keep
the game going I play Rook e to but then
he plays Rook G8 and it's black with
full control on the king side
threatening Bishop takes G2 I defend but
then he plays Queen C1 Rook F1 Queen
C5 and I actually ended up flagging in
this position like my time ticked down
to zero and I tried playing Rook F2 but
I had already flagged if I did get in
Rook F2 he just takes on G2 and yeah
this is resign for
whites so um yeah ended up losing the
game after somewhat of a messy finish um
or kind of unfortunate finish on my end
which I I never actually ended up
winning the bishop and I missed my
chance to take it so I think now is a
time to check the the engine analysis
and see what the critical moment was now
I I already have a pretty good idea of
the critical
moment so let's just go
into this graph yeah I'm definitely not
a perfect game on my part
a lot of inaccuracies two blunders one
mistake my first inaccuracy was in the
opening like I didn't even realize that
this is a a wrong move order for black
if we just look with engine here oh I
was wrong earlier about Knight Knight
B5 I'm was just supposed to take on
D4 I guess it's a good like version of
an open Sicilian with um yeah black
having committed to a lot of pawn
moves so okay that's um that's useful to
know
so I didn't play D4 and then actually
all of this was like clean
play and really even through like Bishop
D5 Rook D4 this is all fine according to
the engine and the key moment was this
position Queen H3 was just a really bad
move goes from almost equal to
completely losing I did have to take on
C8 and engines giving a small Plus for
black oh yeah he could have taken on
F5 but then what is this line Queen C1
King H5 wow because if King G7 I take
and then Queen G5 is coming with some
peret so maybe in a different Universe
we could have got this position with
black trying to play for a win avoiding
the
Perpetual but yeah after after Queen
H3 uh I I just yeah I did not have
enough and it's a sad mistake it reminds
me of a quote
from Kaden trough there is one year at
us championship this was maybe back in
like 2014 or
2015 he said something like one of my
biggest weaknesses is trying to be a
genius where you you try and like create
a masterpiece every game and sometimes
it it comes back to bite you and I think
that's what happened to me here like I
was trying to be overly genius with like
my queen moves and really I should have
just taken the the bishop and one back
material so yeah what to do um it was a
fun game I'm not too upset I think I'm
going to end it here it was a long day
but I had fun uh after the game I I did
a few interviews I was interviewed by
CHP India I was interviewed by the
official tournament or organizers shout
out to KY who took me to the fan Zone
and um yeah I signed a lot of autographs
and took selfies with people I think
there is someone taking photos or videos
so maybe I'll overlay this as b-roll for
for this recap but anyway I'm ending it
here I'm currently one out of three
another game tomorrow and stay tuned for
more Recaps I'll see you guys soon